[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
مبعوث امريكا الخاص بايران يردد بمواجهه
المحتجين خطر الاعدام وروما تحتج على
ممارسات طيران
معارك عنيفه جنوب غرب بخمس وروسيا
تحذرنيتو من عواقب تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
متقدمه
البدايه مشاهدينا من افغانستان حيث افاده
مراسل العربيه
مشاهدين امريكا
عبد الله وماذا نعرف عن ملابسات هذا
الانفجار اكثر
نعم فقد حدث اليوم او صباح اليوم
انفجار في مركز مقاطعه تاخرتها لقانون
الشهير والمقتظ
بالمدنيين وهذا الانفجار استهدف مركزا
صحيا بعبوه الناسفه بحسب
الاحصائيات الاوليه والابتدائيه فان ثلاثه
من المواطنين اصيبوا في هذا الانفجار ولم
يعلق المسؤولين المسؤولون الحكوميون همم
احيانا هذا الانفجار باي تفاصيل ومن
الممكن ان همم يعني ان يرتفع او الترتفع
حصيله الضحايا والمصابين همم
جراء هذا الانفجار الذي استهدف من منطقه
مقتضه همم في مركز هذه المقاطعه الشماليه
وهذه العمليه تعتبر الثانيه عمليه تحدث في
المقاطعات الشماليه اذ كانت هناك عمليه
استهدفت قائدا ميدانيا لطالبان وار قتيلا
وكذلك قتل في تلك العمليه همم ثلاثه اخرون
من همم حراسه الشخصيين يبدو ان الجماعات
التي تناهض حركه الطالبان في حكمها همم
تكثف عملياتها وكذلك
تحركاتها وانشطتها الحربيه والتمويه هذه
الهجمات يعني هل دفع ذلك السلطات الى تبني
استراتيجيه او اجراءات امنيه محدده لتصدي
لهذه الهجمه
طالبا تتخذ واتخذ الاجراءات مشدده ومكثفه
فهذه المراكز مراكز المدن الكبرى همم
ترضخوا او خاضعه للنقاط التفتيش المكثفه
ولكن لحد الان طالبان يعني
اخفقت في ااا في منع مثل هذه الهجمات خلف
هذه الهجمات فيما يبدو عقول المدبره تدبر
بتخطيط لتنفيذ هذه العمليات
تفوضى بالخامه يا عبد الله وسعد اليك من
جديد في سياقه هذه النشره
مشاهدين قناه الامميه ضد سياسه ايران
متعلقه بالمراه فقد حظ مجلس الامن الدولي
طالبان على التراجع عن السياسات التي
تستهدف نساء والفتيات في افغانستان معربا
عن قلقه من التاكل المتزايد لحقوق الانسان
في البلاد ردا على قرار الطالبان منع
الفتيات والسيدات من العمل في المنظمات
الاغاديه اعلنت ست جهات اغاثيه تجميد
اعمالها في البلاد في حين ارد مسؤول
الحركه بالتشبث بقراراتهم
يقفوا الشعب الافغاني امام مفترق طرق وضعه
امامه قرار طالبان لمنع النساء من العمل
في منظمات غير حكوميه
والطالبات الافغانيات من التعليم الجامعي
فان لم تعد الحركه عن قرارها وهذا ما هو
متوقع على المدى القريب قد تواجه البلاد
شبح المجاعه وفق تحذيرات منظمات الاغاثه
في بلد يعتمد بشكل كبير على المساعدات
تداعيات شل نصف المجتمع الافغاني من
المتوقع ايضا ان تشكل خطرا يتعدى حدود
افغانستان
وفقما اكد مفوض الامم المتحده السامي
لحقوق الانسان
حتى الساعه 6 منظمات اغاثيه علقت انشطتها
على الاراضي الافغانيه ما دفع حكما الى
توقف توزيع الاغذيه والمعدات الطبيه
والعلاجيه التي يحتاجها قسم كبير من
الافغان
وبالارقام يعتمدوا نحو 38 مليون افغاني من
اصل 41 على المساعدات الدوليه
وفي مؤشر على تداعيات التعطيل تشغل على
سبيل المثال لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه ثمانيه
الاف افغاني بينهم ثلاثه الاف من النساء
اللجنه اصابها قرار طالبان فحذرت في بيان
لها من عجزها عن تقديم الخدمات للمعوذين
تاتي هذه التطورات غداه تحذير سابقا
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالميه الذي طالب بشكل
عاجل بمليار و 100 مليون دولار لمواصله
تقديم المساعدات الغذائيه خلال الاشهر
السته المقبله الى 18 مليون افغاني يعانون
من انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد وسته
ملايين منهم على شفا المجاعه العربيه
نعود مره اخرى الى مراسينا اميتابل مراسل
العربيه عبد الله نادر اهلا بك عبد الله
من جديد اذا عبد الله كيف تتجلى اشكال
المقاومه الشعبيه هذه الايام طالبان
الاخيره المتعلقه بعامل المراه في
المنظمات وايضا حقهن بالجامعه
لاذعه من الاوساط الافغانيه لهذه القرارات
الاخيره التي اصدرتها طالبان حيل منعى
الفتيات من الجامعات وكذلك من معي السيدات
من العمل في المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه
وهذه الانتقادات من الاوساط الافغانيه ما
زالت تستمر وهناك ادانات دوليه اسلاميه
وعربيه كذلك يبدو ان هذه الضغوطات اذا
كثرت فانها ربما تؤدي الى تراجع طالبان من
هذا القرارات وهذه وخاصه هذه هذين
القرارين وفيما وصلتنا همم
التقارير من داخل طالبان بان طالبنا الان
تناقش هذه القرارات الاخيره وهذه التقارير
من داخل الطالبان تفيد بان همم هذه همم
بان حركه طالبا سوف تتراجع من هذه
القرارات وخاصه همم تعليم الفتيات في
المدارس الابتدائيه وفي الجامعات وستبدا
المدارس الابتدائيه بحسب هذه التقارير
الابتدائيه
تفتح هذه المدارس والجامعات ابوابها همم
امام الفتيات همم بدايه من العام المقبل
الذي يبدا بعد ثلاثه اشهر همم لدى اطلاله
فصل الربيع الانتقادات والاذانات مازالت
مستمره فيما تقول الامم المتحده بان لديها
برامج همم خدمه ل 19,000 شخص افغانيا
بينهم 10 اطفال واذا ما تم تفعيله هذه هذا
القرار الاخير التابع لطالبان فان هذا
العدد الهائل سيتضرر هذا القرار همم هناك
منظمات اخرى كذلك تفيد بان تقديم خدماتها
الصحيه والاغاثيه والتنميه دون مشاركه
النساء لا يمكن بما في ذلك اليونيسيف
ونظمته الامم المتحده للطفوله وكذلك
الاطباء بلا حدود تقول بان هذه المنظمه
همم بدات انشطه منذ 40 عاما في افغانستان
وان خدماته لا يمكن تقديمها الى شعب
الافغاني دون مشاركات النساء
العربيه عبد الله نادر
مشاهدينا نتبع هذه الصور المتداوله لضحايا
الانفجار الذي طال مركزا صحيا في مدينه
صور متداوله لضحايا الانفجار الذي طال
مركزا صحيا في مدينه طخار وكان سكان محل
يوم مشاهدينا اكدوا ان الانفجار اسفر عن
اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص كحصيره الاوليا وهو
ايضا ناجم عن عبوه ناسفه مزروعه قرب
المركز الصحي في تلقان عاصمه المحافظه
احتجاجات الايرانيه مشاهدينا حيث قال
المبعوث الامريكيه الخاصه
بالامن القومي في محاكم الثوره التي لا
تسمح لهم باختيار محامي بدورها قالت منظمه
حقوق الانسان في ايران غير الحكوميه انما
لا يقل عن 100 ايراني
هذا مشاهدينا او استدعى وزير خارجيه
ايطاليا انطونيو تاجاني السفير الايرانيه
في رام الله الاحتجاج على ما وصفه بالقمع
غير المقبول تظاهرات التي تقودها النساء
في ايران
وسبق اندان الوزير الوضع في ايران واوصفه
بالعاري غير المقبول وقال انما ما تتمنى
نهجا صارما في الدفاع عن المراه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن روما مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه رفعت النجار اهلا بك رفعت
ومعلومات او فاعل الموقف الايطالي الرسمي
عما يحدث في ايران
نعم كما ذكرت في مقدمه الخبر تماما
اعلنت ايطاليا احتجاجها رسميا على
على ما يحدث ضد المراه
الايرانيه وعلى
تظاهراتها همم وحدث هذا الاحتجاج يوم
الثلاثاء وهمم
الوزير الخارجيه همم يعني انطونيو كياني
اعقب البيان الرسمي همم
استدعاء السفير محمد رضا صبوري سفير ايران
في روما استدعاه صباح الاربعاء
هذا الاحتجاج
واعلم فعلا كما ذكرت في المقدمه ان
ايطاليا ستنتهي دونهاجا
شديدا همم ضد همم همم
ضاعت حقوق المراه ضد استخدام العنف همم مع
همم المراه همم الى اخره وهذه طبعا همم
هذا ما المح من ملامح السياسه الايطاليه
همم الجديده بالنسبه لحكومه جورج ميلوني
همم
ليس الدفاع فقط عن حقوق المراه همم ولكن
عن حقوق الايرانيين في التظاهر بصفه عامه
وضد ما يحدث ضد يعني
على ان هذه المواقف المهدده الايطاليه قد
تتحول الى اجراءات او قرارات عمليه ضغط
فاعله ضد النظام الايراني وممارسته
هذا سؤال فعلا في محله
وبالفعل اليوم وزير
الخارجيه كياني لوحه بالعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين ايطاليا وايران وايران
ولكنه قال ان
رئيسه الوزراء ميلوني اا تفضل على الاقل
حاليا الاحتفاظ
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه همم
من اجل همم
السياسه التفاوض مع ايران بخصوص برنامجها
النوويه
وبالتالي هو تحدث فعلا
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه في لقائه مع همم
السفير الايراني في روما
ولكنه قال ان تعليمات رئيسه الحكومه هي
الحفاظ
حاليا على العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
ولكن الاستمرار في الضغط والاحتجاج همم ضد
همم
الممارسات همم غير المقبوله كما اا وصفها
وزير الخارجيه ضد المراه الايرانيه وضد
التظاهرات الايرانيه
مراسل العربيه رفعت النجار تحياتي
مشاهدينا مشاهدينا تداول ناشطون فيديو
صرخات ابنتي احد ضحايا الاحتجاجات كمال
احمد بور الابنه تبكي على الوالد في مراسم
مرور 40 يوما على مقتله وكان كمال احمد
بهور اصيب بجروح خطيره على ايدي قوات
الامن الايرانيه وتوفي في تاريخ المستشفى
في الثامن عشر من نوفمبر الماضي في مدينه
مع بعض الكرديه بمحافظه اذربيجان ام
الغربيه
وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه بالفرنسيه
عاما ويعيش في فرنسا انتحر في مدينه ليون
احتجاجا على القمع في بلاده ونشر الطالب
مقطع فيديو عليه انستغرام قبل انتحاره قال
فيه ان الوضع المؤسسه في ايران كان السبب
وراء ذلك
السلطات والشعوب الدول الغربيه لمشاكل
الشعب الايراني لا استطيع تحمل هذه
الاهانه في داخل ايران ولا في خارجها حتى
ولو كنت اعيش حياه هادئه هنا وفي مدينه
متحضره
ورغم ان الرجال السياسه والامن في فرنسا
هم اشخاص عقلانيون اكثر من الشرطه
الايرانيه الا انني لا استطيع تجاهل مشاكل
الشعب الايراني
حيث نقرت وكاله مهره الايرانيه عن المتحدث
باسم لجنه الامن القومي ايران ابو الفضل
العمومي قوله ان بلاده لا تنوي تراجع عن
مطالبها في المفاوضات النوويه وشدد على ان
احياء الخطه الخطه العمل الشاميه المشتركه
يمكن تحقيقه من جانب ايران لكن النتيجه
تعتمد على واقعيه الجانب الاخر واضاف ان
التحليل الاوروبيين لتطورات الداخليه
الايرانيه غير دقيق وروج لسوره خاطئه بانه
طيران مستعده لتقديم تنازل في مقابل
المجاهدين قال مسؤول الامنيون في اسرائيل
ان تحولات ملتقبه على ساحه الدوليه ستؤدي
الى استئناف المحادثات النوويه بين ايران
والقوه الكبرى وذلك
واضاف ان التقديرات الامنيه الاسرائيليه
تشير الى الولايات المتحده معانيه
بالتوقيع على اتفاق النووي مع ايران على
الرغم من تصريح بعدها الاخيره معتمرين ان
تل ابيب تنظر لاقوال بايدي التي قال فيها
الى اتفاق النوويه قد مات على انها زله
لسان اكثر من كونها تصريحات ملزمه
ايران النوويه اذا الى تدخلات طيران
الاقليميه حيث قال دبلوماسيون غربيون بعد
زيارتهم لسوريا لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط ان
ايران تضغط على سوريا للحصول على تنازلات
السياديه واتفاقات تتضمن امتيازات
الايرانيين وشروط قاسيه وذلك مقابل
المساهمه في حل الازمه الاقتصاديه الخارقه
في سوريا واكد الدبلوماسيون عن طيران
فاجات دمشق خلال الاعدادي لزياره الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم الرئيس التي كان موعدها
الاولي امس الثلاثاء بتقديم مسودات
اتفاقات تتضمن ان يعامل الايرانيون في
المستشفيات والمؤسسات العلميه وحقوق
الملكيه وغير ذلك كما يعامل السوريون وانه
في حال ارتكب الايرانيون الجريمه فانهم
يحاكمون امام القضاء الايراني وليس السوري
مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
كوسوفو تغلق اكبر معبر الحدوديه مع صربيا
وواسطه التوترات بين البلدين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد حذرت الخارجيه
الروسيه
لاوكرانيا باسلحه الرقميه يمكن استخدامها
الالكترونيه جاء هذا التحضير على لساني
نائب وزير الخارج الروسي اوليكس الذي اتهم
بتوزيع الاسلحه الرقميه بدون مراقبه عبر
اوكرانيا
وتاتي هذه التصريحاته بعد ان اكلته سياسيه
سابقا ان عدد الهجمات الالكترونيه من قبل
امريكا ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد المراكز
المعلوماتيه الروسيه زادا بعد الحرب
الاخرانيه
موسكو
واضاءه اوسع على هذه التحذيرات الروسيه
كانت ميرارا قد حذرت من ان الغرب يشارك
بطريقه غير مباشره في هذه الحرب
ويستخدم ويسمى بالحرب الهجينه ضد روسيا
ابتداء من تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح همم
وانتهاء طبعا بالحرب الالكترونيه التي
اليوم تحدث عنها نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه بانها زادت هذا العام بنسبه 80%
كان هناك صد ل 25000 همم هجمه الكترونيه
على المرافق الحيويه في روسيا طبعا هذا
ياتي نتيجه لذلك الرئيس الروسي قد اصدر
مرسوما في وقت سابق لتخلي عن جميع
التقنيات التي تاتي من الدول غير الصديق
التقنيه الالكترونيه
لحمايه المرافق الحيويه كما تحدث في وقت
سابق ايضا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الرشيد
قال ان هناك نحو 350,000 من القوات تم
تجديدها من قبل الناتو القوات الالكترونيه
التي تعمل وتقوم بشان هجمات على المرافق
الحيويه الحكوميه في روسيا ونحو 200 همم
1,000 من الذين يعملون في الهكرز همم تم
تجديدهم ايضا بالتعاون بين واشنطن وبولندا
همم ودول وبريطانيا ايضا كما حدث نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي التي تقوم
باستهداف المرافق الحيويه الروسيه سواء
كان قطاع المواصلات او الطاقه
الغربيه لكن هل هناك هجمات الالكترونيه في
وقت السابق همم تعارضت لها روسيا تبنتها
اوكرانيا قبل او بعد هذه الحرب على نقول
همم وهل هناك استعدادات روسيه ايضا
بالمقابل لتصدي لاي هجمات المستقبليه
[تصفيق]
كما ذكرت لك هناك نحو 25000 هجمه
الكترونيه كانت تعرضت لها المواقع
الحكوميه بشتى مجالاتها هنا في روسيا طبعا
لن
تعترف او لم يصدر عن الجانب الاوكراني
اااه اي تصريح فيما اذا كان في المسؤوله
ولكن كما تحدث المسؤولين الروسيه تاتي من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
عبر القوات
الاوكرانيه عفوا ليشنها هجمات على المرافق
الحيويه وبالتالي نتيجه لذلك كان الرئيس
الروسي وقع مرسوم لحمايه المرافق الحيويه
بانشاء اولا نقاط حمايه لكل المركز حيوي
ومؤسسه حكوميه وثانيا طبعا تخلي بالشكل
همم بشكل تدريجي عن جميع التقنيات
الالكترونيه التي تاتي من الدول التي
تعتبرها روسيا طبعا بغير صديقه لحمايه هذه
المرافق والمؤسسات الحكوميه وطبعا الدرجه
الاولى المصارف احمد
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه في بيانها
اليوم ان قواتها تخوض معارك عنيف ضد
مجموعه الروسيه في جنوب غرب محمود بدون
ازكا واشارت الى التصدي لعمليه الهجوميه
روسيه في محور افديتك حيث تسعى القوه
الروسيه الى الوصول الى منطقه مارينكا
لقاطع الامدادات عن الجيش الاوكراني كما
افادت هيئه اركان الاوكرانيه بان المدفعيه
الروسيه تواصل ضربتها على طول خطوط التماس
بدون
مشكلات كبيره في امداد القوه الروسيه
بالدخائر المدفعيه
للحفاظتها الحاليه للعمليات الهجوميه هذا
وقال صحيح ان القوات الاخرانيه اقتربت من
استعاده
اوكرانيا بعد معارك عنيفه مع قوه الروسيه
وتعتبر المدينه الصغيره ذات موقع
الاستراتيجيا وتعرف ببوابه الشرق حيث تعد
بوابه لمدينتين اكبر بجوارها وهما
سيفردونيستك وهو مركز
شرقيه التي سيطرت فيها اوسكار
في اول زياده لاوكرانيه منذ بدا الحرب
فيها يصل اليوم وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
سيباستيانو حيث من المقرر ان يلتقي نظيره
الاوكراني وروكسي ديزني قاف وفقا لوزاره
الدفاع الفرنسيه ويتوقع ان تشهد زيارته
اعلن الفرنسيه عن تقديم ما بين سته الى 12
مدفع سيزاره من عيار 255 ملم تضاف الى 18
مدفعا من الطراز نفسه كانت باريس قدمتها
ياكيف منذ بدايه الحرب
هذا وناقش الرئيس الاوكراني مع رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه مساله تزويد بلده
بانظمه دفاع جويب يشار الى ميلاني
ستزوركيف مطلع العامل
التي قدمتها لنا السيده ميلوني اعلنت انها
تجري مناقشه توريد انظمه دفاع جوي في
الوقت الحالي اننا نتصرف في انسجاما
واعتقد ان الدعم الايطالي سيسمح لنا
بتقويه الدفاعاتنا وحمايه سماءنا
حضر رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا من ان الحرب
الروسيه احدثت ضرر واسعا في البنيه
التحتيه في اوكرانيا الماضي وفي تفاصيل
حصيله الادرار قال المسؤول الاوكراني ان
نحو 35.000 مشاهده تعطرت منذ بدايه الحربي
من بينها 700 من مرافق الطاقه الحيويه لا
سيما انا بنقيل الغاز ومولدات الكهربائي
اين يساوي نصف محطات الطاقه في البلاد ما
يعني ان اجراءات صارمه في استهلاك الطاقه
حتى حلول الربيع
مشاهدينا الكاتب الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا
بقصيده بابا معنا في هذه النشره وداعا
نبدا بتطورات الميدانيه ماذا يحدث في بخم
تحديدا
نعم بالفعل يعني تستمر منذ فتره طويله
القوات الروسيه بالهجوم على مدينه الجيش
الاوكراني اعلن ان هناك وحدات جديده من
فاجنر والقوات الروسيه اضافه الى بعض
الكتائب او المجموعات الشيشانيه كانت
تحاول بالامس الهجوم من الجهه الجنوبيه
لمدينه باحمد ولكنها اصطدمت بالدفاعات
الاوكرانيه التي استطاعت قبل ثلاثه ايام
ابعاد يعني
مراكز الروسيه الى بعد 10 الى 12 10 كيلو
متر من حدود مدينه احمد ولكن المدينه
تتعرض للرجوم بشكل مستمر على مدار الساعه
تصرف مدفع يقصف بالهون بصواريخ الجراج
وايضا بمحاولات تقدم من القوات الروسيه
التي تحاول التسلل وضرب مراكز القوات
الاوكرانيا لكن الجيش الاوكراني وهيئه
الاركان في بيانها اليومي اكدت ان الجيش
الاوكراني يثمر يستعد ل- تكرار عمليه
الهدوم المضاد كما حصل قبل ثلاثه ايام
عندما تقدم الجيش الاخراني الروسيه وايضا
يعني النقطه الاساسيه الان هي مدينه
كريمينيا القوات الاوكرانيه بالامس
استطاعت الاقتراب واصبحت شبه محاصره
لمدينه ارمينيا القوات الروسيه او يعني
بحسب سرجها داي قائد او الحكم العسكري
لمدينه لوجان لمقاطعه لغز قال ان الجيش
الروسي بدا ينقل عنتاده من مدينه كلمينيا
الى مدينه روبيزني وهي المدينه التاليه
مدينه كلميني يا بتعتبر نقطه اساسيه لانها
تعبر الطريق لقوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه ربه
يعتبر ان الجيش الاوكراني بدا يدخل بشكل
كبير داخل العمق مقاطعه ايضا في المنطقه
او في محور الجنوب لقطعه الجيش الروسي
حاول الهجوم
وقصف الا ان القوات الاخرى وهناك تبادل
مستمر مساء الامس حتى هذه يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه في قصائد في الهاون
ما يتعلق بالوضع على الميداني تحياتي لك
لكن ننتقل الى جزء اخر وهو خبر مفاده ان
روسيا حضاره النيتو من امداد اوكرانيا
باسلحه رقيه ماذا نعرف ايضا سيد محمد عن
همم القدرات الاوكرانيه في التعاطي مع هذا
السلاح ضد روسيا
قبل الرابعه والعشرين من شباط تعرضت
المراكز الحكوميه وبعض المطارات
الاوكرانيه والمراكز الاساسيه لهجوم يعني
من هكر وهجوم الكتروني او سيبيري لذلك
الجانب الاوكراني شكل يعني فريق دفاع يعمل
مع الاداره الرئاسيه ومع وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه لحمايه ال- يعني المواقع
الاوكرانيه الاساسيه وخاصه ومواقع وزاره
الدفاع والجيش الاوكراني وهيئه الاركان
وايضا شكل ايضا الفرق للهجوم الاستدراني
لضرب شبكات الاتصال الروسيه لدرس خطوط
الامداد الروسيه كل ما يتعلق بوزاره
الدفاع الروسي شكرا على الكاتب الصحفي
محمد تحياتي
تحيات
ي الخبر العاجل نقنع الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث
عن المناورات مع الصين شملت اسرع غواصه
المعاديه واشتباكا مسلحا مع سفن حربيه
وسنافيكم بمزيد من تفاصيل حاله وارجيا حول
هذا الموضوع اذا مشاهدينا اعلنت روسيا حضر
بيع البلدان والشركات التي تلتزم بصقف
اعلى لسعره بمره بستين دولارا للبرميل
بقرار من الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع
واستراليا وفقا للمرسوم الذي وقعه الرئيس
الروسي بلادي بورسين فانه سيحضر تسليم
النفط والمنتجات النفطي الروسيه على الدول
الاجنبيه والشركات التي اعلن التزامها
بالسقف السعر وذلك بالامن في فبراير حتى
يوليو من العام المقبل
مشاهدينا ايضا نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مقاطع مصوره جديده للمناورات مع بيلاروسيا
مشيره الى ان هناك تنسيقا قتاليا في
مجالات الاعتراض الصاروخي واطلاق قذائف
الهاون وغيرها من الاسلحه في ساحه التدريب
[موسيقى]
نتيجه القصف الروسي سكان
الصغيره على بعد حوالي 30
يستعيدون لموجه شتاء قارس في الافق وظلام
دامس بعد تدمير معظم محطه الطاقه ومخاوفه
من تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
نشاطره مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
سلطته بوفره الامريكيه المختلفه بالثلول
تستعينه بالشرطه العسكريه
استهدافه مركز صحي بعبوه الناسفه في
محافظه تخرج شمال افغانستان و30 اصابات
كحصيله اوليه
الانتفاضه نسائيه ضد طالبان والامم
المتحده تدين قرارات الحركه بحق المراه
وتصفها بالانتكاسه
مبعوث وامريكا الخاص بايران يردد بمواجهه
عشرات المحتجين لخطر الاعدام وروما تحتج
على ممارسات طهران
معارك عنيفه جنوب غربي بخمس وروسيا
تحذرنيتو من عواقب تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
متقدمه
على الدوله ورموزها ليس من حريه التعبير
بل يعد مسلسل
خلال اجتماع مع رئيسه الوزراء على انه لا
ما جاء لتفريط في المؤسسات والمنشات
العموميه عكس ما تتم اشاعاته مشيرا الى ان
الديمقراطيه يجب ان تمارس داخل مؤسسه
الدوله ولا يمكن ان تكون مواجهه ضد وجودها
ووحدتها بحسب تعبيرها اذا مشاهدينا في خبر
انعاكس ارتفاع اسعار العملات الاجنبيه
وصعوبه الحصول عليها سلبا على المصريين مع
تقييد البنوك المصريه لاستخدامات بطاقات
الائتمان في الخارج تنخفض عدد المصري
الخارج عند ابو العزم والتفاصيل
عندما سافرت جوليا لدراسه الكمبيوتر
والهندسه في هولندا لم تتوقع ان تواجه هي
واسرتها صعوبه في التحويل وتوفير العمله
الاجنبيه لتواجه جوليا مشاكل يوميه منذ
سته اشهر اثناء دراستها في هولندا
وانا قلت الاهلي انا عايزه اخذ الكارت
بتاعكم وادفع به اون لاين ادفع به اون
لاين يعني المفروض باربي بس كان بيحصل
مشكله جوليا اصبحت تواجه الكثير من الطلبه
المصريين في الخارج احنا عارفين طبعا
المشكله عندنا
مشكله في مصر من شهر ثلاثه تقريبا او من
معدات الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
فالناس اريد عارفه عارفه ان اولادي في
مشاكل في الدولار وفي مشاكل في العمله
وتوفير العمله الصعبه ايا كانت نوعها
فدلوقتي العدد احنا ممكن نقول ان هو قلب
بنسبه 50% اللي هو الناس اللي بتقدم عشان
تدرس بره ومع صعوبه تدبير العمله الاجنبيه
وفي ظل وجود سوق موازين او ما يطلق عليه
السوق السوداء فرضت البنوك العامله في مصر
قيودا مؤخرا على استخدام بطاقات الائتمان
وخفضت حدود السحب النقدي والشراء من
الخارج بعد رصد ممارسات خاطئه باستخدام
كروت لمواطنين مقيمين في مصر لم يغادروها
في اعمال تجاريه وشراء الذهب والسحب
الدولار من الخارج
شركات السياحه كانت بتحجز همم رحلاتها
بطاقات الائتمان فهي بتمارس عمل تجاري من
خلال اداه استخدام شخصي فهنا فيه سوء
استخدام
غير انخ سعر الجنيه مقابل ارتفاع اسعار
العملات الاجنبيه قد يكون عامله جذب
للسائح الاجنبي
هل ده يؤثر على عدد السائحين الوافدين او
كذا قلت لا مش قبل 7 اشهر
للخارج خاصه للسياحه فضلا عن التاثير سلبه
على سفر المواطنين للعلاج اه الدراسه
راندا ابو العزم العربيه القاهره
تعكس الاضرابات التي تستهدف بشكل اساسي
انقطاع النقل في بريطانيا خلافات
العماليه التي تهدد بيت الصعيد
على اوضاع العمال
اقتصاديه كبيره فيما تحاول حكومه الخروج
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الذي لم يمضي على
توليه قياده الحكومه ثلاثه اشهر بفوضه
جديده في البلاد بدايه العام المقبل مع
رفضه مطالبه نقابات برفع الاجور
الاضرابات تتضاعف عددا ورقعه انتشارها
تتسع لتشمل قطاعات عده بعضها يشهد اضرابا
لاول مره كاضرابات قطعي الممرضين والاسعاف
في ديسمبر اضافه الى تهديد نقاباتها
بالمزيد من الاضرابات في يناير ما ينظر
بمرحله مقلقه قد يواجهها البريطانيون في
عام 2003
يومين اذا تعرضت جدتك لازمه قلبي
الحكومه حيث تشير استطلاعات الراي الى
تراجع الشعبيه حزب المحافظين الذي يحمله
عمال القطاع العام مسؤوليه الحياه الناس
الاخير
ومعرفه عن تحقيق مطالب النقابات لاسباب
يقول انها اقتصاديه يتجه سوناك الى فرد
قوانين تضبط حركه الاضرابات قوانينه تثير
الجدل في بلد يعطي قيمه كبيره لحريه
الاحتجاج
هؤلاء العمال
الظروف لموظفين واذا كان ذلك يعني اضراب
العمال فليكن ولكن اذا جعلت ذلك مخالفه
للقانون فانا لا اعتقد ان هذا امر عادل
المزيد من الاضرابات هو الطريق الوحيد
للمضي قدما بدا من انقطاع الصحه مرورا
بالبريد وحتى القطاع السكك الحديديه ومع
اتجاه السوناتا لطرح قوانين للحد من
تحركات العمال هذا لا يبدو ان النقابات
التي تملك زخم الاضرابات تنوي التراجع عن
خطوطتها قبل تحقيق مطالبها من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه
مدد التايوان وخدمه العسكريه الزاميه
الرئيس التايوانيه التي اكدت على ضروره
استعداد بلادها لمواجهه تهديده الصين
المتزايده ياتي هذا امل ياتي اعلان تمديد
الخدمه الالزاميه بعد يومين بمناورات
عسكريه صينيه بالقرب من تايوان تقول بكين
انها تجري ردا على استفزازات لم تحددها
وعلى الطماطئ بين الولايات المتحده
والجزيره التي تتمتع بحكم ذاتي
اكثر من مناوره عسكريه وتاي ونفهمها جيدا
تدرك تايبي حجم التهديد ان وقع المحظور
تزداد وتيره المناوره الصينيه العسكريه
رسائل وتريد لها بكين ان تكون قويه وشديده
اما طيبه فترد تدريبا وتسليحا اخر
الاستعدادات للاسوء تمديد الخدمه العسكريه
الالزاميه من اربعه اشهر الى عام واحد
بدايه العام 2024 غير ان الجيش التايواني
يواجه صعوبه في التجنيد بدوام كامل
وبالاحتفاظ بالعسكر لقله الحوافز الماليه
لا تملك الا ان ترد بتكثيف تدريب جنودها
وتعزيز الدفاعاتها بزياده المشتريات من
الطائرات المقاتله والصواريخ المضادات
للسفن
لكن هذا ليس كافيا بحسب خبراء ففي حال
وقوع نزاع فان تعداد الجيش الصيني الذي
يبلغ مليون جندي وتفقه العسكري يتجاوز الى
حد كبير عديد الجيش التايواني الذي يبلغ
88,000
الا ان تلك المقاييس قد لا تعني سيطره
عسكريه صينيه في ما لو قررت غزوه يون
فسيناريو روسيا في اوكرانيا ما زال حاضرا
الواضح ان بكيل لا تتردد في ارسال رسائلها
المباشره ترد على استفزازات وعلى تواطئ
بين واشنطن لا بل وتصاعد فالتدريبات
الصينيه الاخيره هي الاكبر منذ ان زارت
رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي طيبه
اغسطس الماضي
ذكر صحيفه جمهور اليابانيه عن الولايات
المتحده واليابان بدات تدريبات لعقد
اجتماعي قيمه بين الرئيس الامريكي جواد
ورئيس الوزراء الياباني فام يوكي شيده في
واشنطن متصفا يناير ونقلته الصحيفه
اليوميه عن مصادر عده الحكومه اليابانيه
يعتزم مناقشه السياسه الامنيه الجديده
اليابان التي جرى تعديلها هذا الشهر
تكتشفه لتكشف عن اكبر التعزيز العسكري
للبلاد منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وسيكون
هذا الاجتماع اول قمه لكيشه داخل البيت
الابيض
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه عن
التزامها انفاق 440 مليون دولار على مدى
السنوات المقبله لتعزيز قدراتها على سد
الطائره الشماليه بدون طياره كما قصص
الوزاره لاربعه مشاريعه تهدف الى تعزيز
قدرات مكافحه الطائرات بدون طيار مما في
ذلك الطائرات المحموله جوا التي تعمل
بالليزر لتدمير الطائرات بدون طيار وجهاز
التشويش لتحديد الاجهزه الصغيره
بدوره مشاهدينا شدد رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
من كوريا الشماليه ردا انتقاميا وقال في
تصريحات النقلتهاب الكوريه انه لا يجب
الخشيه من سلاح كوريا الشماليه النووي بل
يجب رد بشكل فوري على اي ممارسات تهدد ان
بلاده جاءت هذه التصريحات عاقب اختراق خمس
طائرات مسيره من كوريا لاجواء الجاره
الجنوبيه كما قدمت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه
اعتذارا عن فشلها في التصدي لهذه المسيرات
تسببت الامطار الغزيره مشاهدينا بسيوني
وشلالات في مدينه البتراء الاثريه جنوب
الاردن مستدعه السلطات الاردنيه الى اجلاء
مئات السياح من المنطقه التي داهمتها مياه
الامطار وبهرت مقاطع فيديو تشكل شلالات في
المدينه الاثريه وتدفق المياه من بين
الجبال
هذا وتسبب تساقط الامطار والضباب الكثيف
في الصين في اصطدام نحو 400 سياره على جسر
الرئيسيين في مقاطعه خنان شرق الصين حسب
مصادر محليه
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام الاول المتحده
يكون اخر رائحه تواجهها البشريه جاءت
رساله بوتيرك بمناسبه اليوم العالمي
للتاهب كما حتى الامير عام جميع البلدان
على مسانده الجهود الامميه لضمان جاهزيه
دوي العالم لمواجهه التحديات الصحيه
المقبله قائلا انه في مثل هذا الشهر قبل
ثلاث سنوات اكتشف الملك اكتشف الفايروس
كانت كارثيه دعم حققونا ينظرون في عمليه
التخريب التي استهدفت محطات الفرعيه
لتوليد الكهرباء في ولايه واشنطن غربيه
وولايات المتحده دعوا السكان لمساعدتهم
على تعقب المسؤولين عن الهجمات التي اثارت
مخاوف من حمله يقف وراءها متطرفون يمنيون
باعت ذلك في ما لم تقدم الشرطه المحليه
الثلاثاء اي وتنعم تشتبه في مسئوليته عن
عمليه التخريب التي ادت الى انقطاع
الكهرباء عن نحو
14,000 شخص خلال عيد الميلاد في تاكوما
جنوب سياتل
في امريكا ايضا مشاهدينا استعان في
السلطات في بوفالو الامريكيه بشرطه ولايه
نيويورك والشرطه العسكريه للمساعده في فكذ
حامي عن طريق المدينه المخترقه بالثلوج
يحدثها دافع وقت يتواصلوا الوفيات التي
تجاوزت سقف الخمسين وذلك بعد ثلاثه ايام
من اعلى في عاصفه في هذه اليويورك منذ
جيرين على الاقل
كما ادى سوق الاحوال الجويه في الولايات
المتحده الى الغاء عدد كبير من الرحلات
الجويه في عدد من المطارات الامريكيه ما
تسببها بتكدس المسافرين في المطارات
وفقدان عدد كبير من حقائب السفر
[موسيقى]
وهذه وقفه مشاهدينا مع ابرز احداث سبتمبر
هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حماتي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العناوين مشاهدينا
استهدافه في مركز الصحيين
ضد طالبان والامم المتحده تدين قرارات
الحركه بحق المراه وتصفها بالانتكاسه
مبعوثه في امريكا الخاص بايران يرد
بمواجهه عشرات المحتجين لخطر الاعدام
وروما تحتج على ممارسات طيران
نهايته هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
كونوا فيها
[موسيقى]